all right kristen mm-hmm kristen uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally the dc area northern virginia
dc i was born in richmond
and uh
my
i mean i guess we were
pretty well-off um
family
good parents i have to say
that's great
but i i have one brother and we were
we were swimmers that was uh
what i did growing up and i was good i
still hold records for that i still miss
it but i was
um you know practiced before school
after school
every weekend we had a meet it was just
i was
all winter and school uh no this was
when i was uh
i swam before i could walk really like i
was swimming
i have records from when i was five in
1984 still so um when i was real little
and then when i was 12 i went to junior
olympics
and
that
the coach that i had for that um
my parents were going to move to
northern virginia so
i went to live with him and
other swimmers had done that you lived
with your coach yeah rather than your
family and
well because they moved and so to in
order to stay with that same coach and
on that team uh i had to live in that
area
and
um
so
i stayed with him and
[Music]
that just ended up being
[Music]
he molested me so
it just wasn't about swimming anymore
and
it ruined everything basically
because i quit
and
i
it was like to this day i wish i had
just
either stuck it out regardless of what
he was doing or just he had never done
that because
that was like the one thing in my life
that i was really
good at like i think probably everybody
has a gift but i would that i was really
good and i
you know
that would have been my ticket
that would have been what i could have
done did he
get caught for this eventually but not
for me i never
um
i never came forward
mostly because later
i had got i was abducted and i did go to
the police for that and that man went to
prison but that was at the same time i
heard that my old coach was getting
caught
so
i didn't um
i just i guess i just didn't want to go
through both things at once or
i figured he was already getting in
trouble and i had to i already had to go
to court in louisiana for the
um
the kidnapping and so
i just didn't say say anything how did
you get kidnapped
i was
driving on my way to mardi gras
and
i got off the interstate to get a pack
of cigarettes
because
i was out
and i
pulled up at um
i stopped i mean this was in shreveport
louisiana but i mean at the time i
didn't know where i was i and i just
pulled up to a red light
and there was a police station right
there it was like a compound multiple
buildings and uniform cops and
everything walking around and a man
well these guys had been yelling towards
me over to the side kind of just like
cat calling and i was ignoring them
basically and he uh
then i saw like a flash
in
one of the mirror i don't know it
happened so fast he jumped in my
passenger side door and stuck a gun in
my side and just said drive
and i thought he was carjacking me so
but even if i had known what he was
doing i hadn't i drove i just did what
he said
um
and i was trying to
act like i wanted to be there and like
kind of like laugh and make things
light-hearted and until he hit me he
backhanded me really hard and i was that
was when i
realized
that i was in trouble
and
i don't know before that i guess i was
pretending
that somehow i wanted him in my car i
even tried to say
um like okay well can i drop you off
somewhere and
because i i need to get back home like
you know like he was gonna get do that
um
but he took me back to a house and
he chained me to a pole in a shed behind
this house and um
i was there for five days almost a week
and
i didn't see anybody else but him and he
raped me a thousand times and
and
i mean i knew i thought he was gonna
kill me i knew
he kept saying he didn't know what to do
with my body
he said that over and over and i was
thinking we're in louisiana you can like
cut me and
throw me in a swamp somewhere and
alligators will probably eat me like i'm
thinking
i can think of what to do with my body
what is wrong with this dude um and
the one time during that whole time that
i saw another person
he was
showing like one of his friends like
that he had me or something and the
friend was like i know her she's a cop
that was driving around and i don't know
why he said that
i don't know who he thought i was but i
was thinking oh my god if they think i'm
a cop like that's even worse but in
retrospect it's kind of like if i was a
cop they would have swarmed you by now
like
but
um
i was tired i was chained by my ankles
and i um
i had been a stripper
before that actually because this was
um
i had been hooked on heroin slightly
before this
not to jump around but uh
and i danced for a while during that and
i don't know if that's what gave me the
idea or her watching true crime maybe
gave me the idea but um
i
was they i
went up to the top of the pole and
pushed the boards up with my um
ankles with the
chains on my ankles they were like
old-timey um
shackles and my feet were probably like
18 inches apart maybe and
until i got the chain on the other side
of the
pole
and
then i fell asleep but i meant to go
right because he only left he would
leave at like maybe like four in the
morning right towards dawn and just be
gone for an hour or two and that was
when i was gonna go but i was so tired
he hadn't given me any food or water
the whole time and i was just exhausted
and i fell asleep
and
then
when i woke up and realized that he'd
gotten laid out oh my god i just
scrambled and made too much noise with
the chain
and um
but i was out and i was trying to run
but my my they were still chained
together but
i was
he came out of the house and he had the
gun but he didn't shoot at me and i
remember thinking that i could feel
him
a bullet like going right between my
shoulder blades i was just sure it was
going to hit me right there for some
reason
but he didn't shoot it
and i don't know why maybe it was never
loaded or maybe it was even a fake gun
i don't think it was a fake gun because
the cops did well
i i got to
a service station and an older lady
showed up there um
after the cops had gotten there and she
said she saw me and sort of saw part of
the incident and so
she was saying that she was yelling for
me to come and hide in her house
and she was then she said i i don't have
a phone but we could have both hidden
and i was like oh my god if i had gone
in your house and then you told me you
didn't have a phone i might have killed
you
um
but
yeah at least she showed up to the
the um service station and the and
they
i mean
i didn't have any clothes on i and i
just had like a tank top that was ripped
and i had blood all over me and i was uh
but no one else between where i ran from
in the service station
made any move to help me they all just
looked at me like
i was in the wrong neighborhood it was
it was sad but
that man had
uh been in prison for 25 years for the
rape and murder of a 16-year-old girl
and
he was on parole for two months when he
got me the parents of that girl and her
brother came to my trial beca and
were thanking me
for putting him back in prison um
because
i mean they fought so he wouldn't be
released and he ended up literally doing
the same exact crime as he did to their
daughter and um
that's that's the reason he kept telling
me
he didn't know what to do with my body
because that's how he thinks he got
caught for that first crime he thought
if he had
made it so they couldn't find her body
he wouldn't have gotten caught
um i mean i don't know if that's
that's true or not i mean maybe but
either way i mean
how sick are you that you spend 25 years
in prison and you're out on parole for
two months and you'd go out and do the
same
it's just
it's just
crazy so you got away i did i got away
and i
um
and he got caught
he got caught
and how they found him was in louisiana
i don't know who built shreveport
louisiana but they
there are roads on the front and the
backs of all the houses which is just
seems like a huge waste of space but
and then the houses look the same on
both sides it's really weird so
i didn't
i was having a really hard time i
thought i could just go in the car with
the detectives and
backtrack where i'd run and find this
location because they
i've realized four or five days
afterward they really weren't at least
working fast enough or hard enough in my
opinion to find him and so i asked could
we go in the car and i could just take
them to where i was
which they did but then after about two
hours i was i found myself like
apologizing to them because i
i just couldn't seem to find it and that
surprised me because normally i have a
pretty good sense of direction and i
but then
right after i was getting ready to say
why don't we just let me stop trying to
do this i saw it and i was just like oh
my god that's it
and
they said okay well let's drive around
to the front side of the house because
it looked like the front side of the
house and with the shed in the yard
which was weird to have a shed in your
front yard but that's what it looked
like but then when they said let's drive
around the front
the other side of the house looked
exactly the same and it was just weird
to have street on both sides
but when we went around the front he was
laying in the driveway changing the
license plate on the car and i was like
that's him
that's him right there and they got they
well we went to the end of the street
and the only thing i asked them was
don't please don't walk him like right
by
the car you know so he'll see that it's
me i don't you know
and they did that and that always
bothered me they did they
arrested him and walked him directly
right by me
so
um
how long is he in for now 99 years
he got 99 years plus
he was i mean he was on parole for he
had been sentenced to 25 years to life
so he really got the rest of that term
anyway um but i was happy for the 99
years because that's just like a jury
saying you know
you're never getting it again we're
gonna give you years that's you're not
going to possibly live through you know
so you went through the thing with your
swim coach and then you went through
this yeah
and i was i think i was already
destroyed from my swim coach and i said
where the drug you started yeah um
because i at first i started drinking in
high school and
um
just a lot and i would drink before
school if i could i just was
trying to
i don't know what i was trying not feel
that's what i was trying to do and
then
it started with smoking weed and then i
was
the guy that i was dating or i started
dating someone that was selling weed and
i basically stayed with him while he
sold
the harder and harder drug each you know
then he started selling coke and then i
was doing coke and along with the
drinking so
i would do the cocaine and
be able to
stay awake when i was drinking too much
and was your family involved in your
life
i mean it was when my my parents um
well my dad started cheating on my mom
with the older sister of these guys that
i went to school with
and she was only four years older than
me when i was 15. so
i found out about it because my uncle
had died and when my parents were away
at the funeral
my brother threw a big party he was only
13 months older than me so we had all
the same friends and stuff so at this
party
um
my brother got really drunk and at like
three in the morning he says
let's call dad's girlfriend and get her
to make us breakfast and i'm like dad
has a girlfriend tonight but he called
her and she came
and
made people breakfast which was weird
and
i lasted maybe
a month or so after that before i told
my mom that my dad
was cheating on her but
she
she must have known because when she
asked me who it was and i was like i
can't
say that because i was a daddy's girl
like i didn't want to really be telling
on him at all but
then i felt so sorry for her
it was a small enough town that it
became like
the biggest scandal there and everybody
knew about it and i felt like they were
everybody i mean everybody did know
about it and they were i don't know if
they were laughing at my mom but at
least talking about her you know and
it's just
i hated that place for that reason i
never
i still never want to go back there just
because
it's just
i don't know maybe too small of a town i
just
anybody that would like
just gossip so much about
one family going through basically a
divorce but somebody cheating or
you know it's just
it was mean i always felt like it was me
and i've always had
more empathy for people than that and
i don't like it when people
treat other people really badly i've had
a hard time on the street because of
that too because that's the norm
treating other people badly but
that makes me that hurts me like you
know if someone's making fun of someone
or just like i've seen people just walk
up and start beating another person for
no reason like no conversation before
just
just being mean i've seen some horrible
things like that and
i don't know why people act like that
but
i've always been
definitely someone to fight for
the what brought you down underdog um i
uh
well i quit using heroin and i was on
methadone
um well because i ultimately started
using heroin because that's the same
dealer boyfriend
uh yeah this part comes a little bit
first he he
i got hooked on heroin because
he's an idiot and he was speaking in
slang to guys in
worcester massachusetts which is 18-hour
drive from where we lived but he was
trying to get coke because we didn't
have we hadn't had coke in a couple
weeks and it was christmas and
at that point people just wanted to
snort something in that small town i
guess so he was going to drive these 18
hours and pick up coke in worcester
massachusetts but they were talking on
the phone using slang when he got all
the way up there driving my car
um
they had heroin and he would not coke
because they were both saying dope or
whatever they were saying they're idiots
so stupid so he bought
the heroine because
he's an idiot and he just wanted to
bring some drugs back i guess
and
so that's how i started using heroin
and
um that same boyfriend ended up um
choking me until i was unconscious and
throwing me over the side of a bridge in
that town and he
he went to prison but only for six years
for that
and i thought that was really low
because if you're trying to kill someone
and you actually think you did kill them
and you're trying to dump their body you
should get the same sentence as a
murderer
i think
but
that was um the last day i ever spent in
that town
so how do you think you've had so many
of these abusive relationships with men
i i
i think
because i
say what i think and i'm opinionated and
i
don't hold back i think i speak a lot
before i think and a lot of these guys
that are like want to be gangster type
guys
will slap you around for that for having
any kind of a
opinion or voice which is why i'm
single forever now
because i don't i'm a horrible judge of
who i should date clearly and
do
42
have children no because i couldn't have
kids and that was what precipitated my
relapse
i mean i was queen for almost 15 years
really and
i'm not now during that 15 years i
actually got married and
then i had six miscarriages and
my whole life i knew i would have kids i
mean
the first place i ever worked was a
daycare center and i i mean i just love
them and uh
when i couldn't have them and then when
i run into girls out here they're like
oh yeah no i have a son and i'm like you
don't have a kid you're out here your
kid is with someone else thank god but
it always bothers me because i'm like
and you're lucky you could have them to
begin with you know here i am i
desperately want them and
um
i ended up using again because
which when you're clean for that long oh
my gosh i was so far removed from
drug use and everything that happened to
me
that
i actually
might have made it i might have been in
that small percentage but
you know
nothing turns out in your life the way
you think it's going to i don't know it
gets kind of um
just well what's the point if i'm not
gonna
if i don't have kids and
i don't what else am i gonna do i mean
i guess i didn't really have another
plan or maybe i was just
punishing myself for
i don't know but
by then
i had moved out here because that was
part of after what happened with that
guy and the whole bridge thing um
i never went well i never was back in
that town again
and
um
so that's really why i came out here
when i was five years old i saw
a picture it was a postcard of the santa
monica pier and it looked like when i
was five it looked like an amusement
park and you know uh when i was older
when i found out that that was somewhere
that you could live and like make money
and i was
they i just thought that was
definitely where i should go
so that was what put l.a in my head
really like the weather and i think the
last winter i was um in northern
virginia it was so cold my
um
my whole car was covered in snow and
once i scraped it then the keyhole was
frozen and i couldn't stick the key in
and i was like oh my gosh i'm done
so um
that was uh
the weather and
that picture from when i was five that
brought me out here but
there's so many people that are
transplants but
well at first it was it was good i do i
remember talking to my mom on the phone
and telling her i was happier than i'd
ever been before because i was you know
just
working and have my own apartment and i
was
in la and it's beautiful here and um
i was not in danger of running into
anyone that i didn't want to see
you know
and so i was comfortable and
um i remember telling her i was yeah
happier than i'd ever been before and
then i slowly just
first i would have
wine like after work with uh people from
work you know and then it's like i think
that's how i
slowly started going towards
relapsing
because it was just a social thing and
then
that's obviously really bad for me
because
i can't just keep it at that and
then
i ended up
not
working at the like i've worked i've had
some
great jobs and um
worked in some really like cool places
like forensic accounting and things
stuff like that that i'm really
interested in to do with like
forensics and crime and you know so
that part of my life should have been
great but
you know i was always sort of pulled
towards
the dark side for some reason
and even my parents my dad i mean my
brother and i both
were heroin addicts and
my dad never even smoked a cigarette and
he he's asked me before you know how did
i end up with 100 of my kids are hooked
on this drug and i never not only did
not do a drug i didn't smoke a cigarette
i never he's never been a drinker just
nothing and he has
100 of his kids
our addicts and
he always feels like what did i ever do
to deserve that it's certainly not his
fault but um
i don't know i
i sometimes i wonder why
i've had
it seems like and unusual amount of bad
things happen to me like i have a
stepfather now that my parents split up
and my dad actually married the woman
that he was cheating on my mom with and
then my mom
was by herself for a long time and then
um she got remarried
and um my stepdad is
he was an ambassador for his whole
career in a bunch of different countries
but he's very straight laced he does not
believe in anything like luck or
bad luck he doesn't
even though i mean to me i've had some
bad luck and um
he
after knowing me for six years he was
like okay you have bad luck i'll admit
it
i mean luck or i have a
i have a mouth or
i have a voice i like to say that's
better
my mouth so much so
but i've loved it out here but not
not until i got
being on the street is not something you
love it's worse than anything i could
ever imagine
how did you relapse
i um
i slowly started with the wine that
then i started buying it for at home
after just like a happy hour thing and
then i ended up
getting laid off from my job that i
really liked and
it was during the time when unemployment
paid you for 96 weeks
before i think it was trump that cut
that off to nothing but since it was so
long
those 96 weeks even though it was way
less than i made i managed to still make
it work
and
just used all my free time to
go back into a deep depression and not
wanting to get out of bed
and
ultimately
searching for
heroin
and um
it actually i didn't know about skid row
i went to compton because i think that's
what it says in like rap songs
or something because that's definitely
where i went and
they directed me to skid row and um
then
i used heroin
um relapsed on heroin and um
didn't my parents didn't know or
anything because they were
they're still back on the east coast and
they still thought i was out here doing
great
and
then
fentanyl came along
and
i started using that
and now
i don't know what the end of the story
is
were you living are you on the street
i am i'm technically i'm in a shelter
right now which is
uh
such a huge
blessing i mean because
it's
unusually hard i remember the first
night i was going to be outside i called
so many places that day because they say
they have like emergency vouchers for
motels and stuff that's not true they
don't
um
and
they were all kind of like scoffing at
me i'm you know like oh well nobody's
even gonna look at your file until
you've been outside for a year and i'm
like
oh my god i was like not even wanting to
be outside for tonight i mean
because at the time even though i was
using i i was thinking if somebody
could
have you know help me with a place to
stay i could at least maybe keep working
and
things wouldn't get so bad
but
i couldn't slow it down at that point it
was maybe i guess too late and then once
you're out on the street
it's shocking how hard it is to
get back inside because no like like
they told me on that very first day she
they were telling me the truth all eight
of those places
were telling me the truth nobody looks
at your file so you've been outside for
a year
and once you've been outside for a year
you're a different person than you were
because
hey the person i was buying drugs from
of all people said i was mad and he was
like no you can't be homeless you're
going to change you're not going to be
the same sweet chris you're gonna be
like hard and
mean like you won't even lend somebody
your lighter
and he was right he was right
because
people do some
horrible things to each other out here
which is so stupid i've never walked by
a homeless person asleep on the street
and thought what could i steal from them
that seems [ __ ] to me but
they do like and it's the worst feeling
i don't know i think i felt worse the
first time and every time after that
that i woke up on the sidewalk and
someone had stolen everything i owned
and i literally just had clothes on my
back i think that was a worse feeling
almost than any of the
other horrific things from the
kidnapping
rapes i don't know i feel like that was
almost worse because that was just
that was just
that was really hard
for some for some reason i don't know
like i guess i felt like
there were people that could help me
with
other bad things that had happened or
well they happened i wasn't destitute
though so i could still eat a good meal
and take a shower
um
after those things happened especially
rapes i mean showering was like
but
this was like
i was already homeless and now somebody
just
somehow made that worse
um
how do you support yourself now
i
steal
from stores and sell it boost it
i wasn't sure you'd know what boosting
was a lot of people don't but of course
you should
um yeah
and i uh
that is hard for me to do because most
of these places um you know i shopped in
with my parents growing up which is
probably
why or how i learned how to behave in
them so i can go into a lot of places
where
some other people might not be able to
really even go in them um
and uh
so i kind of feel
i it feels bad i remember standing at
some counters in department stores and
macy's and stuff when i was a kid
and my mom being like where is this
checkout lady you know but we never
would have left the store because there
was no employee you know that never
crossed anybody's mind
so
they're not being an employee to check
you out now being such a good thing
is kind of weird
but
then it is it's you know
makes you enough money to get by but
having to do that every day is
rough
does this lifestyle affect you
emotionally
it's it
has worn me completely down because
it's just
it's just such a waste you know like uh
and it's sad i mean i had managed to go
through all these other things in my
life but not get
you know tangled up in
police issues you know and but when
you're boosting every day you're gonna
eventually
get caught for things like that so now
it's like i've got court dates that i've
missed and
i'm just
waiting for
i guess to get arrested and go in on
those warrants because anything else i
do before that happens i still am going
to have that so i just feel like
now my life is embarrassing for you to
used to be a great swimmer that yeah had
a lot of potential enough yeah and now
i'm yeah and it's the reason i won't go
i mean my dad and they want me to go
back there and spend time in like a
long-term rehab and i'm like how could i
even go to that area i wouldn't show my
face
anywhere like i would be too scared of
running into someone
that knew how
good i had it before
and like for them to see me now it's too
it's too embarrassing i couldn't
do it i just um
and also i mean
about a week ago i was
sitting on a sidewalk
down the street from a mall that i had
just boosted at and i was starting to
fall asleep and i i wrote with my marker
i wish i was dead on the sidewalk
and when i woke up it was because these
two cops were waking me up
and i was still i guess half asleep
because i had taken a xanax too once so
i was kind of out of it and not i hadn't
really thought ahead to them taking me
to jail because somehow i was thinking
i wasn't doing anything wrong so
i don't know what i was thinking i
wasn't thinking clearly but especially
well so then when i was handcuffed while
they were searching everything
um i still somehow wasn't thinking i was
going to go to jail
oddly but
they didn't actually take me to jail the
cop the one cop it was a man and a woman
and
the man asked me
if i wrote that on the sidewalk and i
told him that i did and i was i was
thinking he was just going to charge me
with vandalism or something and
um
then
i don't know he he was like you know
what um you have two warrants but i
think you need a break so we're just
going to let you go
i couldn't believe it
i don't know why he did that
but
it made me think like
you know well he let me go but the next
person like i don't know right does that
mean i'm supposed to go turn myself down
i don't know
i just
i can't believe that my life is
what it is now
kristin what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned after
all of this
that
it's just
drugs and just not the answer it's just
a temporary fix because everything that
i've done drugs for like to numb myself
and to not feel
all that stuff is still there when i
quit which is
why i don't want to quit but then what
does that mean i'm supposed to use drugs
for the rest of my life that's not
practical either i mean i'll end up in
prison it's true what they say because
in order to support yourself what i have
to boost okay so i'll end up in prison
long before i would use for the rest of
my life i mean there are a lot of people
oding right now i have never od'd
somehow oddly never
so i don't know why that is but
i have no stories of
using too many drugs i use a lot but i
just have a high tolerance oddly i don't
know i have all these people that are
dying from fentanyl
sometimes it feels like it doesn't even
get me high enough
and i don't even it's not even the high
it's like just the numb
but
that's definitely drugs are not the
answer if i could ask god or whoever put
us here
to
take one thing from me it would be
depression
because i was clean for 15 years i'm
pretty sure i can lick drug addiction
but i use because of depression
mainly and
that's what i would want him to
absolve me of
because that's the
worst
the worst feeling i literally i can't
watch a an animal like a dog that looks
like it's like maybe the brunt of the
litter and i was this happened yesterday
so there was this one little dog that
was like going in the corner by herself
and looked so sad and i'm literally
sitting there thinking is she depressed
because that would kill me
um like
and i that's the dog i'm going to pet
and try to make happy because
yeah it's the worst feeling in the world
being depressed
i mean anything that drive you to this
type of life is definitely
you know it's got to be a
really bad feeling
all right kristen thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck out there thanks
you